hi welcome thank you for coming for my
talk today I will talk tell you about
the project we mean solutions did weave
together with gift about predicting
flight compensation and I will tell you
things that can happen about things that
can happen when trying to implement such
a machine learning project so what is
gift is a company that helps passengers
to get the compensation for disrupted
flights this is the main reason for this
compensation is you two six one
directive it's a law that lets passing
lets passengers get compensation for
flies that are a delight for more than
three hours or canceled or may be denied
boarding I think like this and the way
the company works is that when a client
comes to a company and so as well my
flight was delayed for hours can you
help me get the money first the claim is
verified so whether this case is
actually eligible for compensation then
this is sent the company sends the claim
to the airline and then airline can
accept the claimant pay the money or
reject the claim and then the claim is
rejected you can go to the court which
is long and tedious process or no one
wants to does it do it hmm
well but hopefully eventually it ends up
in plane getting the money and the
company gets a cut of this compensation
if it's successful and to tell you about
the size of this market so there are
four billion passengers annually one
billion of those passengers comes from
European Union and making some estimates
about how many flights are actually
disrupted you end up with that there is
five billion of viewers available for
should be paid in conversation to
passengers every year this this number
is not realized because many people
don't know about this and sometimes the
airlines reject the claims but this is
the scale the potential scale of the
market so
when can passenger get the compensation
so there are basically three situations
when there is a delay more than three
hours when the flight is canceled and
you do not get a flight alternative
flight within two-hour window or where
there is over booking and you're denied
the the boarding the plane but so the
there the it's not so simple
so you cannot get compensation when the
delay is less than three hours when you
get the alternative flight but there are
also other conditions like the asterisk
on the on the compensation which can be
summarized as the extreme weather a
strike on the airport site or some other
rare events like lightning hits the
plane or plane hits a bird on its way
then there's are unforeseeable
circumstances and then the airline Air
Line is not obliged to pay you and the
problem we want to solve is to automate
the verification of times so a client
comes with a claim and we want to answer
the question so should we take this case
should we say the client yes you are
entitled to a competitive compensation
and the standard approach in the machine
learning project is to first collect the
data train the model deploy the model
and then hopefully profit from this so
the perfect model the simple the way you
would life love to solve it looks like
this first you check if the flight is
eligible because this you two six one
directive is applicable only to airlines
that operate that originated in the
European Union and to flight that
originated from EU so not all flights
are can be compensated then if yes then
is the delayed greater than three hours
or the flight is canceled well if yes
then so was there some extreme event
like weather strike birth heat this sort
of thing well if no then you're entitled
to compensation and it looks very easy
if you have the perfect data
but you often don't have perfect data
and there are complications in this
world and this further decision point so
maybe there was a strike but it wasn't
strike on the airport but the airline
was on strike the employees of airline
decided to go on strike then you still
are entitled to compensation
basically if if the delay or
cancellation is the airline's fault and
the the strike of airline crew is
understood as an airline's fault then
you're entitled to compensation but if
it's not airlines fault and the airline
could not foresee you don't get the
money so another case is maybe the
strike was on the previous airport so
the plane so it goes from one Airport to
another then another then another then
another and there if there is a strike
on some Airport previously on the path
of that plane then this still counts the
airport strike say then this still
counts as unforeseeable circumstance so
you can already see that this this
further choice is extreme by the whether
a strike question and this is not so
easy and for this we we need machine
learning to solve the problem we need to
collect the data right so we need flight
information this so information about
what was the actual takeoff time it when
the flight to when the plane took off
the second thing we need when it landed
actually so was it on schedule or was it
light well you know we need to know the
airport's we we need to know all your
data of this type and this data of this
type can be bought you simply need to be
busy it's very hard to collect it
yourself but there are providers that
collect this type of data and you just
buy the buy this information this is not
always perfect because depending on the
provider you sometimes get the data with
a two day delay or sometimes there is
some missing data some flights are
missing some data about flight or
missing mmm the other
other type of data that we need is the
information about whether and this we
get from something called matter weather
reports they are issued every 30 minutes
for every airport and then contain
information more useful for the flights
so like visibility wind strength
one direction etc etc and you can get
them for free there is the US agency
that provides this data but the data is
still not perfect so example of Safie
that happens a few days ago like two
days ago we Excel the system extracted
the weather report that you can see on
this picture this this long string at
the bottom is this is how the report
looks like but there is also something
that it's supposed to be the hour of the
report and there is a teeter and what
time was the report generated I know
that would query the the service at
around 8 a.m. so this is probably 8 a.m.
but and sometimes this data is missing
completely there are problems with the
data and there are the other things like
strikes hitting Birds and this is hard
this is hard mainly because this hitting
a bird affects the next flights of the
plane so if a plane hits a bird on its
way then it needs to be checked for for
damage and then this delays the next
flights and we tried extracting this
information from Twitter accounts that
tweet about aviation and it didn't work
because it didn't really match well with
the data we have ok so we have this data
that is not perfect hmm so we collected
the data but there were a lot of things
missing so of course you can say change
the provider of the data and this is the
basic thing if your provider providers
data misses has 20% of flights missing
then well you maybe need to change
change it so we tried that mmm you could
manually fill missing values so the
if things the the process that happens
in the company is instead of human
verifying the flight as when there is
missing data so you get the case and
then the case has no arrival time and so
you cannot say what was the delay mmm so
then someone will check it in some other
data source like fly trader or other
service of this type and manually feel
the values in the database and then this
to switching to a new data source and
implementing this process of fixing the
data this improved the percentage of
total created cases without enough data
to make a judgment from between 15 and
20 percent of cases to 8 percent sorry
this last number is not very readable
hmm and so this is one thing you can do
when the data is not perfect you can try
to fix this you can also try to extract
the information need from the data you
have so I said that we try to get the
strike information but they didn't
succeed but we what we can do is we can
count compute study statistics about
disrupted flight on airport and the idea
here that is that if there is a strike
on the airport or there is an extremely
bad weather around the airport there not
only this one flight will be disrupted
but many flights will be disrupted and
this actually correlates very well with
the with airline rejecting the claim if
there were many disrupted flights on the
say departure Airport or on the target
or the arrival Airport then the airline
will usually just reject the claim for
for money so this is another approach
you can use to somehow get the data but
get features from history that help you
mm-hmm and having done all this so we
train the model we try we use light DBM
to train them all also this is dance
of small decision trees if if you don't
know and we use it over each boost or
something like logistic regression or
our single big decision tree because it
worked it worked better and it was easy
to use so like things like categorical
very values were handled well from the
from the start and our model had
something like 25 250 features most of
them were the airport statistics so if
you wonder why there are so many
features of this type it's because you
have two airports one where we start
from the one where you land on every of
those airports there are flights that
come to the airport and flight the
depart this Airport so you can count
them separately you can count to a virus
the ranges of delays like disrupted
flight is this one that is delayed more
than three hours but there are maybe
smaller delays maybe a lot of smaller
delays and this is also an indication of
some other problem also I mentioned
before that if the airline is a strike
then you're not entitled to compensation
so we calculate the statistics all those
statistics as I said we're excluding the
airline you're traveling with so this
this is used to like if your Airlines on
strike
then probably only flights by this
airline will be disrupted so all if you
calculate the statistics for all the
other airlines you will get that
everything is fine and we had weather
features so features extracted from the
weather reports they were less useful
because there were a lot of these
reports are not very consistent between
airports so sometimes on one Airport you
will get some information another you
will not so it makes it hard to use to
actually use as a feature in the model
and the 20 30 20 feet are other things
like an airline yeah sort of maybe
categorical features type of flight
which is it a low-cost flight or not and
this this model had the AUC score of 0.9
t1
so the area under curve and the ROC
curve right this the the true positive
rate versus false positive rate is you
can see here mmm and this is the area
under this curve is 0.9 t1 so this was
this was our classifier now the very
important part of of implementing the
model in a company that that has some
existing process where humans do some
work is explaining the model it's
telling that in proving that your model
makes sense and so explaining the model
is very important so the the light GBM
model is nonlinear so it's harder to
interpret but still a lot can be done
and there are many there are a few
methods to do that one is like the basic
one is to look at the future importance
and there there is gain in number of
splits so again is when you calculate
how much you gained in terms of the loss
function when using this feature to in
your tree the number of splits is how
many times you used this feature as a
decision point in the in the trees and
this gives you only global future
importance and this is how it looks for
us I grouped up the various so to not
show you 250 features I grouped them up
by type so there are statistics about
departure Airport arrival Airport which
have very similar number of splits
whether that has a bit less so half life
so 50% of that maybe even less and other
which are even less important but again
a number of splits are not very perfect
you cannot use them to explain a single
observation and there have some other
theoretical faults so there is a better
way it's Shubb values there are sharply
additive explanations introduced in the
great paper a unified approach to
interpreting model predictions by
scotland Burke and swingley so these are
based on Shapley values from game from
game theory this can be calculated
quickly for three models
so the mole a type of model we have and
this can be used to explain single cases
this is something really great where you
can so the way it works is the you
calculate the expected effect of this
feature on the output of the model and
there is a very nice Python library
called shop that you can use to plot to
visualize the feature importance in many
different ways and also this is recently
has been added to both light DBM and xD
boost so you can just when use the
predict method from this libraries you
can just get the these sharply values
and so one type of plot a simple plot
that looks similar but similar to the
previous one is the absolute sharp
values where again I grouped the
features and here it looks like the
departure statistics are a bit more
important than the arrival Airport
statistics and the weather is less
important than the other features are
even less important so it looks similar
to the previous plot but but not not
identical and so this is looking at this
type of plot certain feature importance
is very important is future importance
is very important well it lets you cut
backs so you can see well you can look
at this plot of all the features and you
can see that maybe there is a feature
here on top that doesn't make any sense
this happened to us like when you make a
back and something ends up used in
training that shouldn't be maybe it
contains the the real answer or is
broken in some other way and ends up on
top in the future importance then you
can catch it up but also the Shapley
values can be used by to explain the
single errors of the model you can look
at well my model so you can look at the
cases you've verified with the model and
people are the company will tell you all
this is wrong
this case is wrong this case is wrong in
this case it's wrong why and you can
look at the individual sharply values
for each case and then maybe realize
that something is wrong with your model
okay so now we have the model we have
explained the model so we are pretty
sure the model is okay now we need to
deploy the model and the way we did that
is we deployed mmm so we wrote a rest
HTTP server we used bottle framework but
but there are alternatives like flask
which was deployed on the Google cloud
using to burn it is and this needs to be
fast or at least fast enough so part of
the job is to make sure it's fast enough
so you might need to profile the code
and when we needed to profile the code
we used C profile and visualized the
profile profiling with tool called snake
V's and then after its deployed we
monitor the performances of performance
in terms of speed and here we used we
use Prometheus and graph Anna to see and
on this plot there is the average
verification time this is a few seconds
so this seems like a lot and it is quite
slow but this is for the for the needs
of the company now right now this is
good enough a lot of this time is
actually used querying some internal IP
API so okay and then you have the model
deployed but still you need to you kind
of just trust your metrics so let's say
our ABC was open 91 this is this seems
good and we measured other things like
accuracy precision recall all this stuff
but this doesn't necessarily tell you
how the model we work in production so
there another thing we did which we ran
in the model in parallel with human
verifications of the employees of gift
would get the case verified and then see
what was the model models answer and
then they will well if the answer was
the same it
then everything was fine and if the
answer was different the answer differs
so what was the reason so what the model
overlooked basically and then after a
few iterations of this process we ended
up with a model that was agreed with the
human verification eighty-three percent
of the cases and was different in
seventeen percent and this was good
enough for the frequent process and this
was deployed in production recently in
November and this and the current
pipeline looks like this there is
automatic verification that handles
cases like the delay was less than three
hours or the flight is outside the scope
of the you to six one directive and this
handles roughly 50% of the cases so 50%
of the cases are just trivial and then
there is machine learning verification
our model that has 11% of all the cases
so 22% of the the hard ones and the rest
falls into the hands of humans again and
there are a the reason why this is so
high is that there is still a lot of
missing data so even when we fix the
data you know even getting providers
there are still problems with the data
sometimes the client will say input the
safe flight number and the airport's and
they don't match and in the model now it
doesn't know and then a human has to
there needs to be contact to explain
what is wrong okay so a takeaway message
so that for this type of project the
cleaning merging analyzing the data
takes way more time than actually
training the model the training the
model like well we run a few experiments
but this wasn't the main part of the job
the main part of the job was to get the
data together and make sure it's so
there are no me there are no missing
values there it it's unavailable there
missing values but you don't have
absolutely like empty rolls into the
frame or something that it is and that
explaining the model so understanding
the model that you created is very
important and it can help you avoid bugs
and gain trust in that that your
solution actually works and there is a
constant need to monitor in the model so
you cannot just run one test and say
okay this this works this is the say
course 83% cases agrees with human
verification because there were changes
the the law changes the company strategy
changes so you need to check this
somehow so the way we do this we
sometimes verify the same cases of the
model and and human verification and
compare the results mm-hmm okay that is
all I want to say thank you very much
for your attention thank you any
questions thanks very much for a very
good talk
you mentioned about shop values and one
of your slides you said you had a pie
chart and it was 83% of decisions to
humans agreed with mmm-hmm just for
curiosity did you when you asked the
humans what reasons they had for
agreeing with the model did you try to
match that against the shop values and
were they very similar we did what we
didn't do that so they think what we do
now is we have a tool for the analysts
that displaces so they can input in the
case number identifier and then they get
for this case what was the what were the
important what were just have values of
the important features so they can look
at that there is no because analysts and
the verifiers there are different teams
and so there is no this was not joined
together so the
the verification that that inputting the
reasons did not see the shop values the
analyst that analyzes later then can
they can look at the champ values yeah
but that will be very interesting to
check and see if the yes yes so it's
even better that they're different teams
yes so this we didn't do and yeah this
is a good idea for to check okay and the
last question is the what was your
decision was your threshold your
classification threshold fifty percent
like your for so the the precision was
supposed to be eighty percent I know but
the decision between the model like so
it's a binary classifier like they get
they will get competition or they won't
so when you had eighty-three percent
agreement among human users did you play
around with threshold at which you
classify a threshold is chosen the way
that the precision on the validation set
is 80 percent okay okay so that that's
how the I don't I I truly don't remember
what is the threshold okay thanks thanks
very much next question no more question
hello I have a question regarding when
you mentioned the hard cases you said
that fifty percent were automated and
the other fifty percent were hard cases
how hard actually these cases like how
hard can they be well not so not very
hard these are hard cases in that sense
that delay is greater than three hours
or the flight is canceled and the flight
is eligible for this compensation and
there are no obvious reasons to reject
all right so did their heart yeah so
this means not very hard but it's not
you cannot reject it immediately this is
so so the way the human verification
work is they they will look at the the
statistics of the airport to or they
will look at the flight Reiner well if
they have doubt they will look whether
there was a storm somewhere or some
extreme weather event and if they don't
find anything like that they just accept
the case now there is here there is a
bit of a game theory because you could
accept all cases and just set it to the
airlines but then the airline would
learn this and then reject all your
cases right so you have to send them you
don't want to lose any and a good case
right so you should be biased towards
accepting not rejecting but you cannot
send everything right and also I saw
that you have like 250 features no for
the model and a human verification how
many of these features actually looking
at the end the human is better than the
yes yes human looks at way less right so
the human verification would look for
things like whether there was a storm
right so it will if he has he or she has
doubts he will look at the some portal
with aviation weather and see if there
was a storm or fog or ice or something
like this or it will look at the news
website looking for a strike information
whether there was a strike so he so kind
of human today the media right the
available data is easier for humans to
extract information from my whether
there was but whether or whether it was
a strike whether there were there was
some problem with this plane earlier so
it is easier for human to extract its
information from the whole internet and
for the model it's harder so the model
needs more features any question okay
maybe a little naive question like I
don't know how quickly the users
submitting new proposals let's say for
claims but can you use like historical
data from the airlines already to reject
or accept what do you mean historical
day I mean if you submit once blindly
and then get answered and if you get the
same claim for the same flight you just
use the historical day I think this is
slow so there so there is a process some
differs airline by airline some airline
will have an online form some airline
will require you to send them a letter
or require it in the past so there is
this difference and I so this is just
you won't get this in seconds right so
we cannot just or even minutes days yeah
so but I don't know that right this is
this is this would be a nice trick but
maybe the airlines would if they would
realize they was just just reject
everything right once you send them okay
is anyone question no thank you
[Applause]